what was your reaction when you saw it  shall I do the cool part when I was like  oh yeah the cod or should I be more like  actually crying we actually got to give  Bo her first peek at her photo it's  really good oh my god okay this is way  they actually bow 23 is from Serbia and  a guest jeans model vet Barbara also 23  is from Hungary and has modeled for 10  years  you guys are specific diet and exercise  I didn't want to take any diet because  ports you say they like curvy girls so  that's what they want actually that's  what they said  that brings us to Ashley Graham the  plus-size model we've met many times but  this is her first SI photo spread this  is huge this is phenomenal this is  broken down a huge barrier